president Trump considers reopening the
economy as a pidemo ologists protests
the media tried to blame Trump for some
dude actually eating fish tank cleaner
and Democrats continue to play politics
with an economic rescue bill I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action right now and expressvpn comm
slash man I really mean that loud people
getting hacked right now expressvpn calm
slash plan to protect your online
activity okay so we begin as always with
your latest updates on the news before
we get to the politics so the
coronavirus map today is showing a vast
increase in the number of deaths in the
united states they're over a hundred
deaths yesterday in the United States
we're up to 591 total deaths at this
hour in the United States from
coronavirus forty six thousand four
hundred eighty five cases diagnosed so
far now we are expecting these numbers
to rise obviously that is not a great
shock again we are testing once we start
testing you're going to start finding
things that you are testing for as
opposed to what China there's rumors
that China is actually continuing to see
coronavirus cases and they stopped
testing and that's why they're not
seeing an increase in the number of
cases that are out there now one of the
big problems here is that China's path
is one of the great hopes for the world
because if China's been able to tamp
this thing down it makes everybody feel
like okay well maybe we can tamp this
thing down too that's why more people
are putting faith at this point than
South Korea which has seen 9,000 total
cases in 120 deaths and has not
completely shut down their economy to do
so the difference being South Korea had
massive testing regimes already in place
thanks to h1n1 and their response to
SARS in the in the past because of all
of that they had been pretty well
prepared for all of this the United
States simply was not in we're late on
the game because we were late on the
game the entire ballgame here has been
how do we shift from Chinese lockdown
strategies everybody stay home into
South Korean social distancing everybody
wear a mask
strategies where most of us can go back
to work if you're sick you stay home if
you're elderly or you're vulnerable you
stay home right everybody keeps saying I
hear this from a lot of people on the
right side of the aisle I don't think
the old people and the vulnerable people
why don't they just stay home and
everybody else goes back to work and the
problem is right now there's too much
social mixing you don't know who has it
and who does not there's no way to tamp
down the people who actually are sick
and so because we have not yet gotten
this thing under control you can't go to
South Korean type measures the quest
is how fast we can get there meanwhile
in Italy the situation continues to be
incredibly grim Italy has about 64,000
cases at this hour with approximately
6,000 total deaths their death rate is
significantly higher than that of the
United States again we have we are
gaining on them in terms of total number
of cases but we have fewer well under
1000 deaths at this point just about 600
deaths Italy has 64 thousand cases in
6000 deaths that is because their health
care system is being overwhelmed and
that is why so many people in the United
States right now are worried about the
overwhelming of our health care system
at this time that is why people are also
worried about a bed shortage looming in
California according to the New York
Times governor Gavin Newsom estimates
California will be short about 17,000
hospital beds although the state is
frantically trying to source thousands
more of them the pace of testing remains
stubbornly slow in California are you
hearing from hospitals in the area that
they are indeed inundated with people
who are coming in for coronavirus
although we have heard no stories about
ventilator shortages at this point in
time
Elon Musk actually came up with a
thousand ventilators yesterday we are
quickly ramping up production across the
country of ventilators of masks of
personal protective equipment that's
those PPE easy here everybody talking
about and the fact is that it takes a
little while for the US economy to get
going on this sort of stuff but once
industry kicks in we are fantastic at
producing what it is we actually need to
produce New York State has conducted
twice as many tests as California for
the virus as of Monday New York has
tested almost 80,000 people including
33,000 in at New York City California
had conducted 26400 tests by Sunday that
was the most recent data available
officials in California have rushed to
reopen hospitals that had been shuttered
by motels to house the state's more than
150,000 homeless people and retrofit
college dormitories to serve as hospital
wards again the homeless problem in
California continues to rear its ugly
head because the fact is that Los
Angeles homeless people are not exactly
socially distancing now all of the fun
and games with regard to letting people
live on the streets and declaring they
have a right to live on the streets and
be a health threat it turns out that has
some pretty serious consequences there's
some video of la homeless folks not
exactly people who are concerned about
cleanliness and social distancing at
this point you can drive around Los
Angeles right now and you can see
there's nobody anywhere but you'll see
large congregations of homeless people
in downtown LA under overpasses by the
LA River none of that it speaks well of
the possibility of tamping down the
Cremona
epidemic gavin newsom said the state is
chartering flights to china to procure
protective equipment china has been has
been hoarding all of that protective
equipment oh those wonderful folks in
the Chinese government it is some video
that we were talking about of the
situation with the homeless in Los
Angeles that looked like a place that is
a thriving and ready for health to you
this is in downtown LA across California
the promise of widespread access to
testing for the virus has not yet
materialized doctors say they were
alarmed about shortages of protective
equipment one of the other big problems
is that the states are handling this
sort of differently and so while
California has locked down in New York
has locked down Texas in Florida have
not yet completely locked down and this
is leading epidemiologists to believe
that there could be hotspots in some of
the states that have not yet locked down
that are not yet measurable meaning the
testing is not happening in in Texas and
Florida the same way it's not happening
in California but lock downs have not
really gone into place in Texas in
Florida the same way they've gone into
place in California either in New York
City the attack rate meaning the amount
of transmission right the number of
people who have this thing in the
general population in New York is much
much higher than anywhere across the
rest of the country so far as we can
tell
New York is actually testing but in
California which is also starting to
test the rates are nowhere near as huge
and that is because of course New York
is an extraordinarily populated area
when you have that many people living
right on top of each other the
possibility of pens I'm a transmission
becomes much much higher that's been
true literally forever this is why when
you read old old books about the plague
hits London and all the rich people
immediately jump in their carriages and
head off to the country cottage there's
a reason for that people are trying to
do that in New York right now they're
trying to flee to Florida in Florida
saying no you guys don't get in stay
home you're not bringing your
coronavirus with you here dr. deborah
birx pointed this out at a at a press
conference with President Trump
yesterday she said yes there's an
alarming attack rate in New York City
here's dr. deborah birx the new york
metro area of new jersey in New York
City and parts of Long Island have an
attack rate close to one in a thousand
this is five times what the other areas
are seeing there through the high
throughput lab investigations we're
finding that 28% of the submitted
specimens are positive from that
area where it's less than 8% in the rest
of the country so to all of my friends
and colleagues in New York this is the
group that needs to absolutely social
distance and self isolate at this time
yeah all of that obviously is true
density is really an enemy in a
situation like this says dr. Stephen
Goodman and epidemiologist at Stanford
University with large population centers
where people are interacting with more
people all the time that's where it is
going to spread the fastest we'll get to
more coronavirus updates particularly
economic updates because we're starting
to ask the UH nasca poll question here
and that is the question that we should
have been asking all along how do you
balance all the policy considerations
and I know that that's considered bad
taste we're not supposed to say things
like how exactly do we generate a policy
that is most likely to save the economy
and also save lives where instead
supposed to say that everything shuts
down until every life is saved and that
of course is not plausible I mean the
fact is that we at some point are going
to have to unlock the economy the
question is how we do that in the safest
possible way that doesn't mean that we
all go back to work tomorrow without any
protective measures it also doesn't mean
that we keep the economy locked down
interminably and forever because that is
not going to happen either people I've
seen a lot of folks who are protesting
that that President Trump and people who
are talking about the economy you're
overlooking human life
how could you overlook human life it's
not that you're overlooking human life
it's that every public policy
consideration is a balancing of various
outcomes that you are weighing and if
the suggestion is that we do everything
we can in the United States to save even
one human life well then we should all
be walking around in bubbles forget
about a pandemic like all the time we
should be walking around in bubbles we
should go back to horse and buggies the
fact is there are lots of things we
could do in the United States to
quote-unquote save lives they also
happen to destroy the economy which
would have its own horrific side effects
so all of this is public policy
balancing and that should not be a none
askable question in fact it's the only
question that is worth asking at this
point when you are talking about
government policy when you're talking
about what exactly the federal
government and state governments ought
to do when you get some more of this in
just at one second first let's talk
about how you are going to look when you
emerge from this situation are you gonna
look sharp are you gonna look cool so
let me tell you something I am NOT a
natural-born cowboy right I'm an
Orthodox Jew from a major city but I've
always had a soft spot for a cowboy
attire and this is particularly true of
boots well a few years back I went on I
got myself a pair
I've never been able to wear them since
because my wife laughed at me and
instead now I'm using the best pair of
cowboy boots you can find because
they're subtle and they are cool you pop
your jeans down over the top of them and
they look like just normal amazing shoes
go check out two Kovas psychobos cowboy
boots are handmade with high-quality
full grain leather by world-class boot
makers these things are unbelievably
comfortable they look excellent they're
built to be comfortable right out of the
box for every occasion at home in the
office out on the town they look
fantastic with tons of timeless styles
two coats are designed to be as
fashionable 50 years from now as they
are today to Kovas cuts out the
middleman sells direct to you at an
honest price that is truly incredible
for this level of quality in addition to
cowboy boots to Kovas also does leather
duffels men's jeans belts billfolds card
cases and more everything you get from
two covers comes with the same
calculated approach and quality
standards that holds two holds true for
everything they do they're really
fantastic fantastic products I love
wearing my Jacobus boots it makes me
feel like a cowboy even though I don't
have to look like somebody who can't
handle cowboy boots do what I did get
yourself a pair of Tacomas cowboy boots
today it's a KO vest calm slash Ben you
are enough of a man to wear cowboy boots
so long as they're tacoma's that is Tec
ova Escom / been sick OVAs comm / ben go
check them out right now okay so the
reason that people are starting to go
nuts about even mild considerations of
public policy is because they are afraid
that we are going to jump one way or the
other that we're going to jump
precipitously back into a vast amounts
of social life with no social distancing
and everybody going back to work and
then millions of people die or
alternatively the economy is going to be
shut down forever and those are not the
only two approaches they'd better not be
the only two approaches because if those
are the only two approaches and neither
one of those is worth choosing but to
pretend that there are no economic
effects of this that we can do this
interminable use of course idiotic
Nelson Schwartz at the New York Times
writes the American economy is facing a
plunge into uncharted waters
economists say there is little doubt
that the nation is headed into recession
because of the corona virus pandemic
with businesses shutting down and
Americans being shut in it's harder to
foresee the bottom how long it will take
to climb back Gregg dico chief US
economist at Oxford Economics says the
economy is assured of a recession output
will fall 0.4 percent in first quarter
12 percent in the second Bowman Sachs
says they expect to 24 percent drop in
the second quarter and Morgan Stanley is
saying that it might be up to
thirty percent in the second quarter
which would be the greatest economic
retraction in the history of the United
States by a long margin on Thursday the
Labor Department reported that initial
jobless claims jumped 30 percent the
previous week in one week to two hundred
eighty one thousand it's the highest
level since the aftermath of a hurricane
in 2017 but Goldman Sachs foresees that
this week this week 2.25 million
unemployment filings this week okay so
this cannot continue forever and so when
President Trump talks about how we need
to stop this at some point that of
course is true and that doesn't mean
that Trump is downplaying this thing he
is not downplaying this thing right
here's President Trump yesterday did a
press conference he said yeah things are
gonna get real bad this week you're
gonna see the numbers go up by the way
the numbers will continue to go up next
week everything lags and as far as the
deaths that lags to because people are
lingering for a week or two at the
hospital sometimes before they die
here's President Trump yesterday saying
yeah things are gonna be pretty bad this
week it's gonna be bad and we have a lot
of people dying from the flu as you know
we have a very bad flu season on top of
everything else it's very bad it looks
like it could be over 50,000 and
certainly this is going to be bad and
we're trying to make it so that it's
much much less bad and that's what we're
doing I think we're doing a very good
job of it the President did announce
some new measures that were being taken
by the federal government yesterday he
said that FEMA is distributing millions
of critical supplies and it is true they
are activating in terms of getting an
n95 masks out to as many medical workers
as possible ramping out the distribution
of personal protective equipment
everybody is indeed mobilizing you know
in a crisis the crisis doesn't stop just
because people are mobilizing the
question is how long it takes to
alleviate the crisis here's President
Trump announcing that FEMA is getting
directly involved FEMA is distributing 8
million n95 respirator masks and
thirteen point three million surgical
masks of course the country right now
focusing on the areas with the greatest
need we've shipped 73 pallets of
personal protective equipment to new
york city and 36 pallets to the state of
washington in the past 96 hours FEMA has
also received donations of approximately
6.5 million masks
we're having millions and millions of
masks made as we speak okay so that is
good news president Trump also says that
we are pursuing coronavirus treatments
in record time they're developing a
vaccine pushing it as fast as they
possibly can
there's the president's on coronavirus
treatments at my direction the federal
government is working to help obtain
large quantities of chloroquine and you
can look from any standpoint tomorrow in
New York we think tomorrow pretty early
the hydroxychloroquine and the z-pak
I think is a combination probably is
looking very very good and it's going to
be distributed with 10,000 units going
and it'll be distributed tomorrow it'll
be available got approved in
record-setting time has never been
anything even close to it president
Trump has been pushing this
hydroxychloroquine solution it is it is
not clear at this point there no there
no tested trials as far as
hydroxychloroquine and any mass numbers
to see whether this thing is incredibly
effective across the board from did pump
hydroxychloroquine again yesterday at
his press conference he's been pushing
this thing pretty hard there been a lot
of stories of people who say they feel
better after using hydroxychloroquine in
coordination with his a--throw myosin as
well as zinc so we'll see if that plays
out it is amazing the lengths to which
the media will go in order to try and
portray from mentioning this thing as a
grave grave evil so yesterday
I mean honestly I was astonished I'm not
sure I've ever seen Trump derangement
syndrome as strong as I saw it in the
media yesterday this is an unbelievable
story okay so a Heidi prism Allah over
at NBC News tweeted out this tweet
yesterday as she tweeted out you'll find
it here oh my god don't take anything
don't believe anything don't believe
anything the president says and his
people because they don't know what
they're talking about and don't take
anything be so careful and call your
doctor this is a heart ache I'll never
get over what exactly is she talking
about here she's talking about a story
in which a woman suggested that she and
her husband had taken hydroxychloroquine
in order to fend off coronavirus even
though they'd not been diagnosed with it
and the
her husband died and she ended up in the
ICU and Heidi pers Billa tweeted her
husband is dead and she's in the ICU
after ingesting chloroquine we saw Trump
on TV every channel all of his buddies
and this was safe she said Trump kept
basically saying it was pretty much a
cure she implored Vaughn Hilliard of NBC
News educate the people according to
Heidi pres Billa the couple did not have
coronavirus symptoms but took the
chloroquine phosphate as a preventative
measure they feared contracting
coronavirus a couple each mixed one
tablespoon of chloroquine of phosphate
with soda within 20 minutes they began
experiencing severe sickness and called
9-1-1 I was in the pantry stacking dog
food and I started sitting in the back
shelf and I thought hey isn't that the
stuff they were talking about on TV and
it was Hilliard interviewed her from the
hospital bed over the phone this is the
most horrible day of my life and it
feels like my heart is broken it'll
never mend its just broke dead like my
husband I'm 61 my husband is 68 we're
healthy
no no underlying no diabetes or lung
issues nothing okay Vaughn Hilliard has
this has this audio with this with his
crazy lady talking about how it was
trump's fault sang about the woman in
the ICU Trump kept saying it was pretty
much basically a curds we have that
audio of this woman talking about
killing somebody because he told them to
take your message to the American public
oh my god okay so according to the media
it sounds like President Trump isn't
pushing chloroquine phosphate and that
some lady took his advice gave it to
herself and her husband and then he died
and she's in the ICU wait until you hear
the punch line of the story which
demonstrates the media are full scale
insane insane I mean this is really is
the most insane case of Trump
derangement syndrome I have ever heard
of and there's a
from derangement syndrome out there but
the mainstream media have picked up on
this story the punchline here is unreal
and it was seriously wait for it okay
first let's talk about the fact that
even when all this is over taxes are
still going to be a part of your life so
you got to make sure that you get those
things right and save money while you
are at it that is why you need to lean
on LegalZoom never has there been a
matter time to cut costs particularly
legal costs then right now as you
prepare for an unsteady future in this
economy
LLC's DBAs s corpse they all mean
different things when it comes to paying
taxes and limiting your personal
liability that's a lot to think about
but Legal Zoom makes all of this easy
I've been using Legal Zoom myself for
years now as a lawyer and long before
they are an advertiser on the program
they've got tons of resources to help
you including their own network of
independent attorneys and tax
professionals they'll provide the advice
you need to ensure you're operating your
business the way you want to and since
Legal Zoom is not a law firm you'll save
time and money while you avoid hourly
fees whether you need to incorporate
form an LLC set up your business and
other way use Legal Zoom to maximize
your business's potential and make your
accountant happy at the same time go to
legalzoom.com today get your business on
the right track for 2020 Legal Zoom is
where life meets legal again never has
there been a better time to make
efficiency happen Legal Zoom can help
you do it why spend thousands of dollars
on lawyers when you can do it
inexpensively and get the same get the
same sort of service Legal Zoom is
fantastic again I can personally attest
they've been doing a great job for
literally decades at this point go check
them out right now legalzoom.com today
get your business on track okay so what
is the punchline to this story where
Trump supposedly killed some dude and
and then put his wife in the ICU after
recommending inappropriate substances um
it turns out they didn't actually have
hydroxychloroquine phosphate in like you
know the medicinal form they had fish
tank cleaner in the back of their closet
and fish tank cleaner hasn't at
chloroquine phosphate and these morons
went in the back i'm advisedly i am
saying this if you take fish tank
cleaner and put it in your body because
you heard on the tvs that chloroquine
phosphate is good for you and it
literally says on the package not for
human consumption and you then down it
with some soda that's a that's on you
okay that's not on Trump that's on you
because you're stupid okay and I feel
bad for you that you're stupid but
you're stupid like there's no two ways
about that I'm
here's the actual story so if I just
told you what NBC told you you would
think that Trump said take this pillow
person took the pill and the person died
right that would be the story but that
is not the story here's the story from
Fox 29 in Arizona medical experts with
Banner Health are warning the public
against using inappropriate medication
and household products to prevent or
treat coronavirus the morning by Banner
Health comes after an Arizona man in his
60s died from taking a substance used to
clean fish tanks at aquariums in order
to prevent contracting kovat 19 and a
statement released on Monday experts
emphasize that chloroquine which is a
medication used for malaria should not
be taken to treat or prevent covin 19
Banner Health officials say the man who
died along with his wife both took
chloroquine phosphate the man's wife
also in her sixties is currently under
critical care officials say both were
taken to a Banner Health Hospital for
immediate treatment after they
experienced immediate effects within 30
minutes of taking the substance most
patients who become infected with Kovan
19 will only require symptomatic keratin
self-isolation to prevent the risk of
infecting others ran a portion of the
statement the routine use of specific
treatments including that medications
described as anti kovin 19 is not
recommended for non hospitalized
patients the FDA has reiterated in a
statement there are no FDA approved
therapeutics or drugs to treat cure or
prevent kovat 19 chloroquine has been
used to treat malaria since the 1930s
hydroxychloroquine came along index it a
decade later and has fewer side effects
the latter is sold in generic form under
the brand name Plaquenil for use against
several diseases the drugs can cause
heart problems severely low blood
pressure and muscle or nerve damage
finding a plaque windows label warns of
possible damage to the retina especially
when used at higher doses but beyond
this um this is not the same thing as
you know fish tank cleaner as fish tank
cleaner that is not the same thing okay
that is like trump saying that you know
there have been some studies that show
the beneficial medicinal effects of a
glass of wine at dinner so you're like
oh well that means the alcohol is good
for me so you go in your bathroom you
take two bottles of isopropyl rubbing
alcohol and you proceed to down them but
if you do that that one's on you that
one's not on Trump because you're stupid
okay but the media tried to blame Trump
for this it's unbelievable I mean truly
it's it's absolutely ridiculous the
amount that the media are trying to turn
this into a Trump bleep show as opposed
to we're all in the midst of a pandemic
and nobody knows anything which is
really the story of this thing and then
we are all sort of muddling through it's
pretty incredible I don't know how you
blame Trump for that one but meanwhile
the media have been Trant trying to
foster debate between Trump and dr.
Anthony Fauci now at this time if you're
rooting for the country you may not like
everything Trump is saying from the
podium you may think that he exaggerated
you may think that he prevaricate you
may think the president from says things
that are not true that he straight-out
says things that are not true so who do
you want in the administration making
sure that the response is handled as
correctly as possible probably one of
those people would be dr. Anthony Fauci
right wouldn't that be the person who
you are actually counting on to keep
Trump on the straight and narrow yet
every question coming out of the media
right now directed and anthony foul
Jia's why won't you rip on Trump some
more why don't you go rip on Trump some
more like please go rip on Trump some
more so the New York Times has an entire
piece today dedicated to the proposition
that President Trump hates pouchy
because if there's one thing that is
guaranteed to ensure conflict it is
media coverage according to the New York
Times the president has become
increasingly concerned as dr. Anthony
foul has grown bolder in correcting his
falsehoods about the spread of
coronavirus dr. faoud the director of
the niña ini AI D the National Institute
of Allergy and Infectious Diseases since
1984 has grown bolder in correcting the
president's falsehoods and overly rosy
statements about the spread of
coronavirus in the past two weeks
and he has become a hero to the
president's critics because of it and
now mr. Trump's patient's has started to
wear thin so is the patience of some
White House advisors who see doctor foul
she is taking shots at the president in
some of his interviews with print
reporters while offering extensive
praise for Trump in television
interviews with conservative hosts Trump
knows that foul chief who has advised
every president since Reagan has seen as
credible with a large section of the
public and with journalists and so he
has given the doctor more leeway to
contradict him according to multiple
advisors to the president when Trump
knows he has more to gain than lose by
keeping an advisor he has resisted
impulses to fight back against apparent
criticisms sometimes four-month long
interludes so far the president appears
to be making the same calculation with
pouchy but the president has resisted
portraying the virus is the kind of
strength Rhett described by Falchi in
the media are trying to play up I mean
this is ridiculous media are trying to
play up conflict between foutch II and
Trump at a critical point where it's
pretty important that Trump be having
open conversations with foul Chi by the
way Trump in his press conference has
been
unendingly and and unstintingly praise
worthy of a foul Chi I mean talking
extensively about how he thinks ouchies
doing an excellent job Trump yesterday
and his press conference despite all of
the talk about how much he hates Falchi
and he's losing patience with pouchy and
questions being asked about to foul a
about Trump being a liar and why don't
you stand up to Trump by the way if you
ever get found you an interview dumbest
question you can ask at this point is
what's your relationship with Trump like
who cares who cares as long as Trump is
listening to him that's all that matters
and why would you try to undermine that
trust if you actually believe that foul
she has something to offer here by the
way again Trump is mouthing openly his
his willingness to listen to both pouchy
and Debora Beck's the person who's
heading out his his his efforts here
we'll get to president Trump praising
Falchi even as the media try to
undermine that relationship in just one
second and then we'll get to the big
controversy of the day which is Trump
suggesting that at some point we're
gonna have to reopen the economy which
again I have a hard time finding it how
this is in any way remotely
controversial if you opens the economy
on Friday that's controversial but
saying we're gonna reconsider this thing
every step of the way that's just called
like being a president that's called
being a politician considering public
policy we'll get to that in just one
second first right now we got to avoid
crowds any way that we can but we also
all have packages to send out we're
relying on the mail more than ever
because you're really not supposed to be
leaving your house well what better way
to get all those packages sent out and
save money in the process then using
stamps.com you might be sending cards to
parents or grandparents you might be
sending packages you might be receiving
packages right all this stuff you can do
using stamps.com
anything you can do at the post office
you can do it stamps calm print on
postage to man print postage on demands
skip the lines and crowds at the post
office practice the social distancing we
are all encouraging everyone to
undertake here at the daily where we've
used stamps calm since 2017 for years
and it has saved us tons of money and
tons of time stamps.com brings all those
amazing services of the postal office
directly to your computer and the safety
and comfort of your own home office
anywhere else you are hunkering down
right this moment whether your small
business sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products you're
just working from home you need to mail
some stuff stamps comm can do all of it
with ease in with stamps.com yet great
discounts to five cents off every
first-class stamp up to 40% off US
Postal Service shipping rights in now in
addition stamp set calm is offering UPS
services with discounts up to 62 percent
so never has it been a better time to
use stamps calm then
right now right now my listeners get a
special offer - it includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and the digital
scale no long term commitments just go
to stamps comm click on the microphone
at the top of the home page type in
Shapiro that is Sam's comm enter promo
code Shapiro okay so as I say the media
have been trying to foster some conflict
between Trump and
pouchy but Trump publicly he's been
saying he's listening to found she hears
Trump yesterday he's very important to
me and I would I will be listening to
him I'll be listening to
Debora who you just spoke to I'll be
listening to other experts we have a lot
of people that are very good at this and
ultimately it's a balancing act but you
know the expression we can do two things
at one time and we've got an incredible
country we have to keep it that way and
that includes not just economics that
also includes life and death okay so the
again he is not going after Falchi he's
actually you know he's actually praising
found you there also Trump says that
that foul she hasn't not agreed to them
so now we get into the big issue of the
day and that is how do we balance the
the needs of the vast majority people
who are not going to die of coronavirus
and the needs of the people who are
going to suffer from coral virus how
exactly do we balance the needs of the
health system and the needs of our
economy these are not separate issues
because the president from what was
raked over the coals by large swaths of
the media yesterday for saying he is not
looking at a month-long shutdown now
again I don't know how this is remotely
controversial okay if the US economy
were to shut for literally three or four
months that would not be something the
United States could recover from truly
because right now we're pumping and
nobody's buying the bonds the only way
to do this would be to inflate the
currency tremendously you can only have
the government backing every bit of
commercial business commercial bonds for
so long the Fed pumping yesterday did
not help the market tell you what did
help the market this morning was the
open conversation that is now happening
about when this thing comes to an end
and that's a conversation that needs to
be had now I've been urging people at
the White House I've been saying for a
long time on the show that what we need
here is a metric of when it is possible
for people to go back to work that does
not mean that the metric is hit on
Friday it does not mean it's time to go
back to work on Monday what it does mean
is that we have to start considering at
which point that line of medical
supplies arises
of the flattened curve right that is
what we are talking about because so far
we've heard no metric from Andrew Cuomo
in New York no metric from Gavin Newsome
no metric from the federal government as
to when we can expect that the resources
that are necessary will be available
such that when we all go back out to
work and there's a second wave of
infections which is what you're starting
to see in Asia right now there'll be
enough ventilators and beds on hand to
take care of that so we can all go back
to work when are the tests going to be
available when are tests going to be
widespread and available such that we
can use 75,000 tested a a hundred
thousand tests a day and we can all get
back to work
we can start to use social distancing
and masks in order to allow us to go
back to our daily life and back to our
jobs gradually as we move toward a
vaccine what do we have to do in order
so that we can up the amount of
resources necessary so we can cordon off
the vulnerable populations from the non
vulnerable populations and contact trace
all of the people who have actually had
corona virus which is exactly what's
happening in South Korea so when
President Trump says we're not looking
at months here that's good because if
you are just watching the headlines
right now if you're the market you're
just watching the headlines the market
is just the aggregate of human knowledge
about the economy and you're watching
the headlines and on the one hand you
have Andrew Cuomo saying this thing
could last nine months and on the other
hand you have found she's saying this
thing could last 12 weeks and you have
minuchin saying could last eight weeks
and then you have President Trump coming
out saying look I'm not looking at
months right this is not gonna last for
months that people start to breathe a
sigh of relief because they think okay
my business cannot last another three
months with no income remetanea all
business loans provided by the federal
government or grants provided by the
federal government like how can my
business remain open eventually this
thing has to open back up otherwise I'm
not gonna invest in my business I'm just
gonna sit home and I'll take the
unemployment insurance instead turns out
that running a business a very risky
enterprise very stressful you know
what's easier is is if they are sending
you a check in the amount of how much
money you were making before and you
don't have to run the business then that
is less stressful and easier especially
if you don't know what's gonna come out
on the other end of all of that right
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
economy right now and Trump trying to
provide some sort of timeline here is
actually quite necessary so yesterday
Trump says I'm not looking at months and
people went nuts here was Trump
yesterday I'm not looking at months I
can tell you right now we're gonna be
opening up our country and we're going
to be watching certain areas and we're
going to be practicing everything
and Deborah's referring to right here
we're gonna be watching this very
closely but you can't keep it closed for
the next you know four years okay this
is going away we're we're gonna win the
battle okay and and then Trump came out
he said listen we don't say no more
driving of cars like where we're gonna
have to have some sort of public policy
discussion about what level of risk is
attendant on reopening the economy
people went nuts over this how could he
equate this to car accidents
how could he equate this to the flu it's
not an equation it's an analogy you
idiots okay every public policy decision
comes with risks and it comes with
benefits this does not mean I've said
this 1,000 times during the show this
does not mean go out enjoy yourself
Spring Break party time
no one is saying that and I am NOT
saying for one that we should reopen the
economy on Friday because I don't think
that that would be beneficial frankly I
think that if the risks are still as
great as they are right now the
coronavirus and we are still as low as
low in terms of data as we are right now
then the economy being reopened is
actually not gonna help the economy
nobody's gonna go back to restaurants at
this point nobody's gonna go out to
theme parks nobody is gonna go back to
work if they can afford to stay home at
this point all right so just saying
quote unquote the economy is reopened
tomorrow does not mean the economy is
gonna just zoom and take off and
everybody's gonna start going and
spending tons of money a lot of people
are risk averse and are gonna stay home
so the until this thing is actually
temps down to the extent that we feel
some level of confidence that huge
swathes of humanity are not going to die
the economy is not going to recover but
when Trump says we don't say no more
driving of cars this of course is
accurate and people who are going nuts
over this are being deliberately
dishonest about this we have a very
active flu season more active than most
it's looking like it's heading to 50,000
or more deaths deaths nutcases 50,000
deaths which is that's a lot and you
look at automobile accidents which are
far greater than any numbers we're
talking about that doesn't mean we're
going to tell everybody no more driving
of cars so we we have to do things to
get our country open and again all of
that is true and he's not saying I'm
gonna reopen the economy on Friday I
think the media are trying to play this
up specifically so that they can play up
the clicks the conflict in him and foul
Qi the click
about people ingesting fish tank cleaner
the clicks about Trump is gonna buck all
the advisers and simply say go back to
work on Monday there's no evidence that
that's what's gonna happen on Friday
okay but considering these things is not
out of the realm of possibility right
even the most ardent shut it down people
like like Andrew Cuomo in New York even
he's admitting this is not this is not a
science and it's not even an art we're
just kind of blindly groping around in
the dark until we get further data which
is to suggest that as we get further
data we're going to have to figure out
how to get out of this here was Andrew
Cuomo saying there was no arts what we
did in New York we may have even taken
the wrong measures in shutting down
schools there is an art form here which
is overlaying a public health strategy
and an economic strategy in other words
what we did is we just closed everything
down as quickly as we could just to shut
all the doors border all the windows
there was no art to what we did there
was no nuance is there a public health
strategy that says look you can start to
bring young people back to work you can
start to test and find out who had the
virus and who resolved from the virus
and they can start to go back to work
and that's how we'll restart the economy
with a smart public health strategy okay
and and he's saying the same thing as
Trump is he's just saying it in more
nuanced form right he's saying and a
certain point we're gonna have to reopen
this thing up and that cannot be forever
okay and that means that we're gonna
have to talk tough risks we're gonna
have to talk about what is the level of
risk because there is no world where
there are no more deaths from
coronavirus over the course of the rest
of the year particularly in a second
wave that's gonna happen and fall has
most of the epidemiologists are
predicting at this point so to pretend
that we're not gonna have these
discussions is really really simple
eerily ridiculous now that doesn't mean
the discussion that's would be ahead in
the dumbest possible way but you know I
think everybody is looking to be
outraged because that's sort of our
usual mode okay the usual mode is
looking for rationales to be out in the
world of politics this is how people
make a buck is to be outraged all the
time let's all just acknowledge we're
all blur all groping blindly there is no
grand strategy at this point until
there's more data we don't know what to
do but these are conversations that must
be ongoing as we add data to this matrix
we can figure out maybe what is the best
thing to do and people are gonna
articulate this in
brusque ways they're going to articulate
these problems in awkward ways and that
doesn't mean that they are saying some
they're not looking for old people to
die on the one hand or for the economy
that can be completely killed on the
other there's nobody has a good answer
here so last night the Texans tenant
governor Dan Patrick was raked over the
coals because he was suggesting that at
some point we're gonna have to reopen
the economy when that happens then older
people are gonna be at more risk which
by the way is 100% true I mean that part
is true you phrased it in a very awkward
way but it happens to be hundred percent
for my own parents have said to me
listen if this meant that we'd have to
basically stay in the house for the next
18 months so that the economy could be
revived then we would do it right the
problem is right now that that won't
work but in the near future that may be
something that has to be considered
minutes what they're doing in South
Korea effectively speaking here was
Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
he's ripped up and down for this last
night no one reached out to me and said
as a senior citizen
are you willing to take a chance on your
survival in exchange for keeping the
America that all America loves for your
children and grandchildren and if that's
the exchange I'm all-in and that doesn't
make me Noble or brave or anything like
that I just think there are lots of
grandparents out there in this country
like me I have six grandchildren that
what we all care about and what we love
more than anything are those children
okay so you know what he is saying may
not be relevant at this moment right
where he is saying okay open it right
back up he seems to be saying open her
right back up and I'll take the risk
okay that that's not his risk to take me
there a lot of elderly people in the
country he's not the only one but in the
near future these are conversations
we're going to have to have and when I
see headlines like this one from a guy I
like Matt Lewis over at the Daily Beast
I mean this is a ridiculous headline I'm
sorry the party of life embraces Trump's
death cult we've skipped over any
nuanced discussion of economic
considerations straight to the part
where Republicans rationalize letting a
million or so people die to fix the
economy nobody is talking about letting
a million people die to fix the economy
okay first of all we don't know a
million people gonna die anyway
these are all estimates we don't know
the answers to this stuff because we
don't have enough data if you asked
epidemiologists what level of certainty
do you have that a million people are
gonna die in the United States my guess
is that most epidemiologists would
suggest not a hundred percent level of
certainty
probably not even a 70 percent level
certainty we are all guessing now
epidemiologists may have better models
than we do and they may they may have
better models as to how the system gets
overwhelmed and how many people die but
there is no level of certainty given the
fact that all of this is fluid and we
are taking measures on the ground as we
speak
these are conversations that we are
going to have to have and we're gonna
have to have them sooner rather than
later because there had best be a plan
and the reason again that the economy is
jumping again today well but not the
economy the wall stir the stock market
is jumping again today is because people
are starting to say ok at least we're
having rational conversations because if
the conversation is we shut this whole
thing down until coronavirus is off the
face of the earth we were talking about
not an economic depression we're talking
about an economic asteroid hitting the
earth and wiping out all forms of
economic life because you're talking 12
to 18 months until there is a vaccine
and again the data that's coming in we
we just don't know how reliable any of
this data is so you know I'm saying the
most annoying thing that it's possible
to say in this circumstance which is I
don't know the answer you don't know the
answer either Trump doesn't know the
answer now she doesn't know the answer
nobody knows the answer all we have is a
formula with a bunch of variables and as
those variables get filled in then
hopefully we can start figuring out what
that equal sign looks like on the other
side of ledger right we don't know
anything yet so right now this is all a
data gathering exercise in the meantime
we are gonna have to have a discussion
about when exactly that equal sign is is
low enough in terms of death rate that
we can all start to move back into into
working so the reason I bring this up is
because there are a couple of different
theories about how exactly we should go
back to work one comes courtesy of Scott
Gottlieb is the former FDA director for
President Trump he's been a very
critical voice in terms of everything
should shut down we need normos amounts
of testing and then there's Ezekiel
Emanuel who is also suggesting lockdowns
will bring you their opinions right now
is he killed manuals kind of an Obama
guy and Gottlieb is sort of a Trump guy
but even that listen I think this is a
necessary conversation I think it's a
good conversation to have people are
treating it as uh nasca ball I don't
think it's uh nasca ball I think it's
very much askable and necessary to ask
and that is when do people go back to
work and what is the metric for when
people go back to work we're gonna get
to that in just one second but if you
haven't had a chance to see some of our
new content called ball access live you
should head over to daily where I come
and go check it out right now
Jeremy boring and I kicked it off last
week all the other hosted live
dreams over a daily wire.com as well
we're gonna continue all this week at 5
p.m. Pacific I'll access live it's
pretty chill I mean so chill that I was
wearing a short sleeve shirt yesterday I
know unthinkable but you could've hung
out with me I was literally just playing
classical music off of my off of my cell
phone so that you could hear some of the
pieces that I liked and answering
questions about apparently they're their
fan clubs devoted to how good-looking I
am I mean I know cuz I'm the only member
but apparently I find I find these
things out during things like all access
why the show is intended for our
all-access members but during this
pandemic shutdown we are all going to
hang out together so as long as you are
a member of any sort you get to access
all access live please let us know what
you think of it I think people are
enjoying it we have like thousands and
thousands and thousands of questions
that were input yesterday join us on all
access live over at Daly wired I can't
come hang out with us I'm trying to
who's going tonight do we know who's
doing tonight a noble's is doing it
tonight
ok so Noel's is doing an all-access live
tonight I am back on Friday is the plan
borrowing some sort of exigent
circumstances so you know stick around
for all of that we've all sorts of
mentioned we're all gonna hang out
together we'll last this thing out and
as I as I said I think that this is
gonna be weeks not months before we
start to figure out a transition plan
but stick with us while we do that over
a daily wire you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so Trump getting ripped up and down for
the suggestion that we may have to
reopen the economy in weeks not months
but it's opened the conversation I think
that's actually a very very good thing
by the way again the markets think
that's a very good thing too because
finally somebody is taking seriously
that side of the of the concern right
the market was up 8% in early trading
like over 1600 points in the early
trading and that is because people are
starting say ok well this won't last
forever ok we don't know what the date
certain is when when we get off the
bench and get back in the game but it is
not going to last forever Scott Gottlieb
has an optimistic piece over the Wall
Street Journal he says soon the United
States will be able to do 75,000 tests
today that will make changes in strategy
possible he says first the bad news
america's coronavirus epidemic is only
beginning the suffering will become more
searing over the next two weeks
hospitals in New York may soon be
overwhelmed New Orleans Chicago San
Francisco Seattle may not be far behind
it'll soon be clear why Koba 19 cannot
be allowed to rage through the country
on tame intense restrictions are
necessary but so is a path back to a
more normal life here's what the
priorities should be in the coming weeks
containment is no longer realistic in
some areas of the United States in other
places it may be possible as public
health authorities learn more about
infection rates in different parts of
the country governments can tailor
strategies to the facts on the ground
there's a trade-off between mitigation
strategies which target large
populations like sheltering in place and
interventions that try to isolate people
who are infected or who might have been
exposed population tactics are blunt
Stern blunt instruments necessary for
isolating hot spots like New York and
Seattle other places may be able to rely
more on individual interventions which
do cause less disruption and economic
damage every state should be taking
steps such as encouraging social
distancing preparing to expand hospital
capacity some events who slow to respond
but for any of this to work the United
States needs widespread testing to know
where and to what extent the virus is
spreading testing capacity says Scott
Gottlieb has increased significantly in
the past few weeks thanks to relentless
efforts from public academic private
labs such as quest and LabCorp a good
reminder that nationalization of
Industry is a dumb idea generally
speaking a new test developed by a feed
can be deployed in a doctor's office
there are people who are talking about
being able to get test results within a
couple of hours or at home test being
available - by the end of next week the
US will have the capacity in place to
screen more than 75,000 people a day
South Korea tested one in 160 of its
people and deploy technology to identify
people who are infected and trace
contents the US should do the same
another step serological surveillance
which means blood tests to detect
antibodies developed to fight the novel
coronavirus which means that if you've
got those antibodies you're already
immune these antibodies confirm unity
can reveal whether a person has been
exposed if a sizable portion of a local
community has some protection
authorities can be more confident in
relying on less invasive measures one of
the problems with lack of testing and
lack of serological content is again we
don't know who's had it and who's
already immune it may be literally
hundreds of thousands of people in the
United States more important is
developing a therapy to treat kovin 19
or perhaps prevent people from
contracting it America's home to a vast
dynamic life science industry this is
its moment one strategy would be to
infuse a convalescent plasma antibodies
from the blood of patients who have
recovered from kovat 19 this could help
boost the immune response in those
recently infected arturro Casa de Ville
of Johns Hopkins outlined such an
approach in these pages last month
perhaps the most promising option is
antibody drugs engineered by biotech
companies a strategy that was used with
success against Ebola also regulators
need to leverage master protocols which
allow providers to test multiple
promising therapies in the same large
trials he says with the right mix of
controlling transmission expanding
testing and deploying promising drugs
American ingenuity can beat back this
pathogen so that is the conversation
that needs to start is ok let's do all
this stuff and how fast can we do all
this stuff
Ezekiel Emanuel is saying we have 14
days to defeat coronavirus he says
America is losing the war right now
against Kovan 19 but we can win it with
decisive and extraordinary actions right
now by the way again I admire the
tenacity of people who say that it is
very very bad to discuss public health
trade-offs while quoting Ezekiel Emanuel
the Obama care advisor who once
suggested that we ought to minimize
treatment for people over age 80 in
order to save medical resources for
people who are under age 80 I'm not
making that up he wrote that for the
Atlantic talking about why he wouldn't
mind dying at 80 okay so now the same
people who had no problem having these
discussions about trade-offs with regard
to nationalized health care are very
unhappy to discuss any sort of
trade-offs whatsoever with regard to
American economic dependence two
pandemics Ezekiel Emanuel says that the
economy can't be fixed without solving
the pandemic which as I mentioned before
is true but if you just open the economy
right now people are going to go back to
work and and not socially a distance
we're all freaked out he says the window
to win the war is about 7 to 14 days if
the United States intervenes immediately
on the scale China did our death toll
could be under a hundred thousand within
three to four months we might be able to
begin to return to more normal lives now
again that's that seems like a pretty
steep estimate under 100,000 when we
have less than 600 deaths in the United
States total at this point but again
that's how exponential growth works
presumably Ezekiel Emanuel says affected
states have have led the way by closing
schools bars restaurants non-essential
businesses by issuing shelter-in-place
orders
this isn't uniform across the country
but it needs to be at least for the
moment and there needs to be social
pressure for local governments to wield
to enforce physical distancing strictly
but compassionately and mayor's should
close streets to vehicular traffic to
make them pedestrian spaces so people
can be at a safe distance also the
President must be honest with the
American people
that the CDC FDA other agencies did not
rule out testing that quickly enough
that's true but we also need to ramp
that stuff up very quickly we have to
conduct random samplings of people to
determine the percentage of population
with coronavirus and the people
percentage of people with the virus who
die with those stats we have better data
we need better equipment reductions as
Ezekiel Emanuel we need hospitals to up
their capacity we need visitors to be
banned at these hospitals we need
businesses to retain workers and keep up
their facilities so they can rapidly
return to operation when Kovan 19 is
under control so everybody's now having
the right conversations okay so this is
the optimistic side of me everybody is
now having the correct conversations and
yes Trump is having that right
conversation too it is not a nun asked
about question it is not a bad question
to say when does the economy reopen in
fact that is the exact question that is
going to lead to the ramping up of
resources necessary for the economy to
reopen if you care about the economy
reopening then you really have no choice
but to discuss what are the cost of the
economy reopening how do we make the
economy robust when it does reopen how
do we get all the resources necessary so
the economy can reopen Trump is right to
think in these terms he is correct to
think in these terms I'm glad that
President Trump is a business person and
he has not a nationalized everything
locked down everything until further
notice guy because that's not what the
government should be doing this is the
greatest work stoppage in the history of
America it is not close it really is not
and if we are not thinking already about
what is the path to get out of this
thing then we are not doing enough
that's not mean we were open to tomorrow
and despite the media again trying to
foster divisions between Trump and
Falchi and despite people suggesting
let's just open this like I have really
not seen eye
there's a bit of straw Manning going on
I've not seen a ton of people saying
reopen this thing up today like we
reopen it completely today I think
everybody understands that we don't have
enough data to do that but the people on
the other side who say that conversation
is verboten you can't even have that
conversation
that's ridiculous strong Manning to
because that like come on come on of
course we have to have that conversation
we're talking about the greatest public
policy either failure or success in the
history of the world right now of course
we have to have conversations about what
metrics we can use in terms of what
risks are willing to take as a society I
feel like I'm beating a dead horse here
but obviously it's not a dead horse
because everybody is too busy going nuts
over president Trump and his supposed
gall and suggesting that we ought to
take into consideration the economy in
having these discussions it is not a bad
thing to ask that question it is a very
good thing to ask that question the only
bad thing would be if we get the wrong
answer to a very very obvious question
okay meanwhile the United States Senate
continues to have this ridiculous debate
over a Senate bill now there are
problems with the Republican Senate bill
those proposed by Mitch McConnell the
bipartisan bill that was pushed at the
end of last week that Chuck Schumer
declared bipartisan and then immediately
reversed because apparently Nancy Pelosi
had his balls in her handbag she showed
up from vacation Chuck Schumer was ready
to sign this thing she shows up and
she's like I want a bunch of random
bullcrap and he's like okay okay sure
we'll do random bullcrap now and so
Pelosi just rejected the Republican bill
out of hand even though it had been
worked on by members of both parties and
then Schumer had basically become her
minion shutting down people from having
discussions of this Republican bill
filibustering the bill in I believe
three separate votes yesterday and it's
absurd because Nancy Pelosi's bill is
just a pork barrel bag of garbage it
really is now listen you can have a
reasonable conversation about the
oversight provisions on the loans to be
provided by the Treasury Department
honestly my preference is zero interest
loans given to the banks that are
already handing out those loans I mean I
think that the right now the banks are
the best are in best position to
determine which businesses are going to
survive and which businesses are not on
the other end of this and backing the
loans that the banks are giving such
that they don't call those in
immediately would be the best available
move I don't like politicians who have
no expertise on the economy whatsoever
no expertise and running businesses I
don't want them deciding how these how
this money gets handed out neither do I
we want the Treasury secretary
determining how the money gets sent out
which is why I sort of support the idea
of the government
yes creating a slush fund that is
handout that that is that is basically a
backstop for the banks because they're
the ones who have undertaken the risk
and the risks they undertake are likely
to be smarter than the risks undertaken
by either Treasury secretary minuchin or
the morons in Congress who can't hide
their shoes but you know with that said
that was not the debate the Democrats
were having ok the debate the Democrats
were having was a completely different
debate so the I mean this truly is
incredible what were some of the things
that Nancy Pelosi wanted in this new
bill what were some of those things here
are some of the new things that Nancy
Pelosi wanted in the bill she wanted
thirty three million two hundred
thousand dollars for the National
Oceanographic and Atmospheric
Association that's what she wanted she
wanted thirty three million dollars in
this and we have to hold up American aid
so we can fund global warming research
she wanted a hundred million dollars for
NASA in this bill and a hundred million
dollars for construction and
environmental compliance what does this
have to do with shoring up the economy
for purposes of of preventing a
coronavirus induced economic meltdown
she wants two hundred seventy eight
million dollars for the IRS three
hundred million dollars in this bill for
the IRS and Nancy Pelosi sees version of
this bill she wanted thirty five million
dollars for the JFK Performing Arts
Center in this bill she's gonna shut
down and hold up the American economy so
that we can fund the JFK Performing Arts
Center deeply vital stuff for people who
are lacking ventilators right now and
for small businesses that are on the
verge of shutting down and going
bankrupt and never reopening their doors
she won in ninety million dollars for an
HIV program in a coronavirus bill she
wanted thirty six million dollars for
the National Center for advancing
translational sciences what the hell is
translational sciences well what she won
in seven million dollars for a specific
DC charter school like the law debt
University Howard University she wants
twenty three million dollars for them by
the way Howard University has an
endowment of six hundred forty seven
million dollars she wanted three hundred
million dollars for the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting we definitely need
to make sure that Big Bird survives
coronavirus here very very important
from Nancy Pelosi and 500 million
dollars for the Institute of Museum and
Library Services by the way kudos to a
Twitter account called oilfield Rando
who has gone through all of this stuff a
million dollars for the sergeant-at-arms
and door keeper of the Senate very vital
very vital stuff 300 million dollars for
migration and refugee assistance because
we definitely need to worry about
migration refugee assistance as we close
every border we could possibly have and
also we need to use more minority banks
expansion of the use of minority banks
and minority credit unions is mandated
in Pelosi s bill we need corporate
boards to have diversity quotas if they
are to receive loans that's exciting
stuff the government is going to force
people onto your corporate board if you
take a loan that you have to take
because the government shut down your
business if federal agencies use any
banks owned by white people they have to
explain themselves seriously the feds
are going to buy 300 million dollars
worth of food and then redistribute it I
can't imagine that they're gonna be
great at that also there's gonna be
another committee the coronavirus on
accountability and transparency
committee also we need a rate support
for Wi-Fi hotspot' and connected that
devices I mean this is just I'm sorry
this is ridiculous also we need federal
election oversight very important to
have in a coronavirus bill okay so all
of this led the Senate to absolutely
explode last night Ben Sasse senator
from Nebraska says Nancy Pelosi is
basically taking hostages here I mean
all she is doing here is holding up the
business of the American people after a
directed government shutdown in order to
get her policy priorities by the way
they're not hiding this right
representative Jim Clyburn from South
Carolina he openly said this he said
that we can use this to push our
priorities here has been saying Pelosi
is taking hostages we got families that
are suffering we got small businesses
that are closing literally by the hour
we have doctors fighting to prevent
their hospitals from being over surged
and overwhelmed and what does Speaker
Pelosi trying to do she's trying to take
hostages about her dream legislation all
sorts of dream legislative provisions
that have nothing to do with this moment
and say the American public can't get
access to the public health piece of
legislation or the economic relief
pieces of legislation unless she gets
hostage
that are entirely unrelated to this
moment we're better than that okay that
of course is true Senator John Kennedy
from Louisiana he said I mean he was
more blunt said listen some of my
colleagues here they're just acting like
a-holes I mean frankly but they're just
holding this thing up for political
purposes and it is amazing the media
coverage what the media will do to
defend Democrats here as Senator Kennedy
yesterday going off on the Democrats
people are losing their jobs they're
losing their savings they're losing the
401 K we think we know how to get the
economy back on its feet over the next
60 to 90 days until we can get control
of the virus and some of my colleagues
they're acting like a-holes I'm sorry
I'm not saying they mean to but
nonetheless they're killing it I mean
obviously that's true Senator Lindsey
Graham who again is a fairly moderate
senator he says Democrats are obviously
trying to prioritize things that do not
involve the saving of the United States
economy at this point look you drive a
car from my living room wall you then
have to reimburse me for the cost of
driving through my living room wall and
that is the first priority and I don't
want to hear from you how I damage your
paint job okay I don't want to hear from
you your alternative priorities here's
Linnet Lindsey Graham going off I mean
again when you've pissed off Lindsey
Graham and Susan Collins and it's hard
to find a more sort of wishy-washy
contingent than that on this in general
in terms of fighting Democrats
hand-to-hand
here's Lindsey Graham saying Democrats
have other other priorities not saving
the American people at this point you
see this as an opportunity to do things
you couldn't do otherwise Republicans
that have to be done now to save lives I
have never been more disgusted since
Kavanagh you tried to destroy a good
man's life just to keep the seat open
and close friends of mine in the house
have publicly said this is an
opportunity to reshape the country and
our image it's not going to happen okay
Susan Collins was shut down on the floor
of the Senate yesterday right she's as
moderate as it comes and Susan Collins
was shut down she just wanted to say
something in Schumer prevented her from
saying anything about the Republican
bill that was being proposed the
Democratic leader objected to my even
being able to speak this morning is that
what we've come to the Democratic leader
objected to our convening at nine
o'clock this morning so that we could
begin working in earnest how can that
possibly be controversial how can any of
us want to see millions of Americans
lose their paychecks their health
insurance their contributions to their
retirement plans misled also to a great
debate between Mitch McConnell and Joe
Manchin joe Manchin of course the
senator from West Virginia and Manchin
was saying well of course we're gonna
filibuster this thing because then you
might pass the bill and McConnell was
like we're not even talking about a vote
on the bill yet we're talking about a
vote to hold the debate on the bill and
you guys are filibustering that here is
Mitch McConnell getting very feisty with
Joe Manchin things were very hot in the
Senate yesterday there's still 30 more
hours we know that 30 hours so in what
way I would ask my friend from West
Virginia would your side be
disadvantaged by that waiting for that
today yes and their agenda just laid it
out very clearly as she always does we
don't have time for this mr. Arky we
don't have time for it let me ask you a
question on the 30-hour question in one
way with the Democratic minority be
because you the majority you have
senator from West Virginia
okay so again he got very feisty
yesterday naturally the New York Times
blamed you guessed it the Republicans
they blamed it Mitch McConnell the
Editorial Board of the New York Times
they said senator Mitch McConnell failed
to do his job this weekend as the
economy spiraled downward McConnell the
Senate majority leader said he produced
bipartisan bail out bail authorizing an
infusion of desperately needed aid
instead McConnell emerged on Sunday
evening with a bill that would provide a
lot of help for corporate executives and
shareholders and not nearly enough for
American workers except the Chuck
Schumer basically endorsed the damn
thing on Saturday night okay the fact of
the matter is that right now is not the
time to wait on this stuff right now we
need the help we need the back step of
the economy and we need the Oh
conversation about when the economy
reopens the fact that Democrats are
putting on the table a pork laden three
times as long bill that nobody has read
laden with crap like money for the JFK
Center for arts or whatever it
demonstrates the utter unserious Nisour
the people in Congress it's why the
Federal Reserve has become basically the
economic resort that everybody uses as a
first resort not a last resort yeah but
bottom line is this this is why you
can't trust government to fix all your
problems and when government imposes the
problems the question becomes how fast
can we get out of this alternative
universe in which the government runs
everything because this really blows and
I understand that the answer is not
today when the answer is not tomorrow
the answer is probably not the end of
this week or even the end of next week
but it better be faster rather than
slower because if you think I want these
dolts running the economy and the
national healthcare it responds over the
course of any long scale period of time
you have to have another thing coming
this is insanity all right we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow for the latest updates I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike pore Amina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen